It should be no surprise
that every community should have
a right to a clean environment.
Yet, some are sacrifice zones.
Sacrifice zones:
communities living on the front lines
of pollution and environmental hazards.
But the good news is that we have
a unique opportunity
to address legacy pollution
as we together build an equitable
and just climate future.
Now, this is a story
about communities in crisis.
Mostly, these are communities of Black
and brown and Indigenous peoples.
It's often a story
of low-income communities.
But race, race is the decisive factor.
Now, studies show that an average
middle-income Black family
with an 87,500-dollar income
is likely to live with more pollution
than a white family
making 22,500 dollars a year.
Now, my organization,
WE ACT for Environmental Justice,
works within a movement of hundreds
of environmental justice groups,
here and abroad,
to address the disproportionate impact
of pollution borne by our communities.
So I'm talking
about environmental justice,
which is a civil rights
and a human rights analysis
of environmental decision making,
with a focus on the permitting,
the permitting process that gives
polluters permission to pollute
within a regulatory standard
for air, water and soil.
Now, these permits,
they are an allowance that sacrifices
the health of community residents.
The cumulative effect of multiple
facilities sited in a community
that emit high levels of pollution
in close proximity to where people live.
That contributes to glaring
health disparities.
Now, Harvard University studies
among Black Americans
living in areas like Harlem
and the South Bronx,
those are communities
which do not need clean air standards
set by the Environmental
Protection Agency.
And those studies that found
that Black Americans have died of COVID-19
at higher rates than others
due to living in air-polluted communities.
Now, that's not a surprise
since the majority of people
who live in areas
that do not meet clean air standards
are Latinos and Black Americans.
And that's the case in an area
called "Cancer Alley."
Now, there's a song
sung by the late Nat King Cole
called "Unforgettable."
And that is what "Cancer Alley" is.
It is unforgettable.
It's in the worst possible way.
It's a 75-mile corridor between
New Orleans and Baton Rouge.
It's a continuum of petrochemical
and plastics manufacturing facilities
on acres of former plantations.
Now, these facilities have created
an intergenerational history
of death from cancer,
with some communities
suffering cancer rates
higher than the national rate.
Now communities experience
environmental hazards
and pollution exposure in diverse ways.
In urban areas,
mobile sources, contaminated sites,
they're really the challenge.
And local governments generally manage
the infrastructure of pollution.
But in smaller cities and rural areas,
industrial and oil refineries,
landfills and incinerators,
they're usually the problem.
And in places like Texas and California,
there may be no zoning laws
that separate industrial facilities
from residential backyards.
So environmental racism and injustice
results from a complex legacy
of housing segregation,
land use and zoning discrimination,
and from unequal enforcement and policies.
Now decades ago,
policies such as redlining
denied home loans to people of color
into certain communities.
And this government policy
reinforced racial segregation in cities
and diverted investments
away from those communities,
creating large disparities
in home ownership
as well as urban heat environments.
A few trees and no open space.
So today we're still living out
the legacy of those racist policies.
Now, I first began organizing
around these issues
as an elected Democratic district leader
in my West Harlem neighborhood.
In 1988, I co-founded West Harlem
Environmental Action,
known as WE ACT for Environmental Justice.
And, you know, we began organizing,
educating our neighbors
to understand the impact
of the disproportionate siting
and permitting of polluting facilities
in our communities.
We started out by pressing New York City
to fix the North River
sewage treatment plant
in the Hudson River
that was ruining our quality of life
by emitting toxic fumes.
And we began to ask ourselves
a number of questions.
How could we transform
the New York City diesel bus fleet
to clean fuel buses
since we housed over 740 of the city
diesel bus fleet in uptown depots?
How could we have a waterfront park
along the beautiful Hudson River
instead of a parking lot?
And how could we get environmental justice
on the agenda of New York City,
the state and the federal government
to invest in sustainability
in our communities?
I know that it only takes one person
to reimagine what's possible,
and some policy change takes decades.
It took us 18 years
to transform the New York City
diesel bus fleet to hybrids.
However, it took only a few months
to ensure that all New York schools
are tested for lead in drinking water.
I know that so much is possible
when we have the right political moment.
But to capitalize,
we must mobilize a critical mass of people
to create real change.
And to monitor that our
policies are implemented
in the way that was intended.
And environmental justice groups
have done just that.
In a number of ways.
So we've created
working groups and campaigns
amongst people who have
a real stake in the outcome,
those most affected
by harm or new policies.
And we engage them
in environmental decision making.
Those are the people
who have the lived experience,
who can best advise on climate adaptation
and resilience planning.
Now, if their perspectives
had been known and integrated
into the inter-agency
emergency response planning
in New Orleans for Hurricane Katrina,
then thousands of families would not
have been stranded on their roofs,
waiting for rescue
or sleeping in a sports stadium,
because the city would have already known
that lower-income families
living in a flood zone
did not have a car to evacuate the city
or a credit card to access a hotel room.
Another tactic we engage is we engage
community in educational workshops
that help them better articulate the data,
testify at hearings,
train residents to become
citizen scientists
who collect their own
air and water quality data
to influence policymakers
and elected officials.
And those officials
should resource every community
to develop a climate action plan
that addresses neighborhood level
response and challenges
to extreme weather events.
We've also developed strong,
strong policy agendas at the city,
state and federal levels,
based on community
perspectives, experience
and the evolving transition
from a fossil fuel economy.
And these are tactics that can be applied
within local contexts in any community.
So as we transition
to renewable energy sources,
we know that energy insecurity
will impact millions more households
as utility bills increase.
And to decarbonize buildings,
a pre-investment will be needed
to upgrade residential buildings
in frontline communities
before electrification
of all buildings will be achieved.
So I challenge you
to create the change we need
by incorporating equity
and lived experience
into all public and government policies.
My vision is to redress
the legacy of pollution
by targeting frontline communities,
not for pollution,
but to become green zones.
Green zones where we can incentivize
community shared solar, electrification,
green businesses, good jobs
and worker cooperatives.
Because today we are
at an inflection point
with an opportunity
to achieve that vision.
You know, the Biden administration
has committed to centering
environmental justice
in all government policies
through an executive order
that directs at least
40 percent of the benefits
from federal investments in clean energy
to go to disadvantaged communities.
So there is an opportunity
to implement a transformative
and accountable process
for the fair and just distribution
of benefits of Justice40
to frontline communities of Black,
brown and Indigenous peoples.
But we must make certain
that the investments and the benefits
reach the communities intended,
given the bias and ambivalence
of many state and local governments.
But if done effectively,
this can be transformative
and could stop the cycle
of exploitation and extraction.
Every community,
every community has the right
to a clean environment.
And you do not need to be
an environmental champion
or a climate justice leader
to embrace that value.
So I call on your humanity
to center the voices
and perspectives in all policies
of those most affected
by environmental hazards
and climate change.
We can create a legacy
of environmental quality
and climate resilience for all.
We can do this and we must.
Thank you.
(Applause)